My name's Penny Jarrett,
I'm a business developer,
youth mentor and blogger
and I have ADHD which is attention
deficit hyperactive disorder.
ADHD is a mental disorder
which causes behavioural issues.
A lot of people think that people
with ADHD can't pay attention
but the thing is, is we can
just pay too much attention
so paying attention to the wrong
things or a lot of things at once.
Sometimes I feel like
I've got eight brains
and each one has 40 tabs open.
I can be talking to someone
and then another tab opens and I just
start thinking about something else
and I give it my full attention,
like I feel like I have
to give it my full attention,
for like three seconds.
People with ADHD
have a lot of energy.
So there's a lot of fidgeting,
we can't keep still.
We usually have
struggles following instructions.
We get distracted a lot,
so it means that
we don't finish things
and sometimes
don’t even start things.
There are loads of good things
about ADHD too.
So an ADHD brain is usually creative,
there are loads
of artists, comedians...
singers, yeah,
there's loads of creatives.
We've got great imaginations
which lead to a good sense of humour,
so we're funny.
And I think that's a lot to do with
just doing funny things all the time,
like I sometimes
find my remote in the fridge.
Managing ADHD includes
managing your environment
so you're not always gonna
have control over where you are.
For instance, if I'm in a white room,
just completely bland,
I find that I start getting
breathless and panicky
and looking around
and just can't focus on anything.
But if I'm somewhere
which is colourful and vibrant,
I feel calm.
And I think that's why my house
is quite colourful,
I didn’t realise it before
but when I got diagnosed I looked
around me and I was like, "OK".
Managing and holding down
a normal nine to five job is mad.
I've even walked out of meetings,
I've been in meeting rooms and
just had the urge to just walk out.
I didn’t even notice until I was
halfway down the corridor that,
"Was I just in a meeting?"
It's just the brain under-stimulated,
it just searches for stimulation
in any way
and if that has to be
outside of that room
then yeah, meetings getting left.
When I'm selling to customers
on the phone,
I make affirmation cards,
handmade with Sharpies and pencils,
and they have positive words on.
Things that I can
look at and remember
when I'm having anxious thoughts
or just not feeling good.
Even if I'm not trying to focus
on something in particular,
like a phone call,
I need to be changing what I'm doing
so that I can give enough
energy to all my tasks.
So if I had a to do list
with ten things on it for the day
where a neuro-typical person
might do each one at a time,
maybe even put
them in order of priority,
I can't always figure out
which one I should prioritise
and that's interesting actually
because people with ADHD have
an interest-based nervous system
so, yeah, we find prioritising hard.
If I timebox myself and
give 15 minutes to each thing
and keep coming back
then I'm stimulated enough
to complete all of them
and at a high level.
I was only diagnosed with ADHD
last year, when I was 30.
So at first it was
such a negative to me.
After doing a lot of research,
I stopped feeling negative
about ADHD
because I learnt about
all the good things.
The best thing about having
ADHD, I think, is hyperfocus.
And what that means is that
we can actually zone in
to that thing for several hours
and it not feel like several hours
and we go in so hard,
masterpieces come out of it.
And that's why a lot of creatives
they master what they do
if they've got ADHD
because when hyperfocus kicks in
nothing will distract you.
Not even hunger or sleep.
ADHD is manageable so it
doesn’t have to remain negative,
and it doesn’t have to
define you in a negative way.
The symptoms of ADHD
are with me, and always will be,
but they don’t have to define me
in a negative way.
If I learn how to manage my ADHD
then I learn how to manage my life.
And I can be just as productive
and successful as I want.
Just not every single day.